first of all I want to get your take on
this meeting with the obr by the Prime
Minister and Chancellor you were on the
obr's committee just how unusual is it
for a prime minister to visit the head
of the obr
um well I should emphasize it's uh the
chairman of the obr visiting uh Downing
Street not the other way around but uh
it's unusual for there to be
um meetings with the Prime Minister uh
there's regular meetings with the
chancellor both of the chairman of the
committee uh alone
and the three members of the What's
called the budget responsibility
Committee of which I was a member
um during the course of preparations for
a budget another major fiscal uh events
um this particular meeting obviously is
quite unusual and the context for it is
quite unusual
do you welcome it happening
from it well I welcome it happening but
there is an element of
um closing the stable door after the
horse is bolted clearly one of the
factors that has contributed to the
market turmoil after the
um fiscal event last Friday was the
absence of any accompanying assessment
of the overall state of the public
finances uh which is what the obr is uh
obliged to provide twice a year
uh normally I'm a side alongside the
budget and uh major
um fiscal uh events
um
if all the government had announced last
Friday was the energy price guarantee
the things that were designed to protect
households and businesses about the
consequences of high energy prices
driven by events in Ukraine
um I don't think there would have been a
problem
um they're not being an accompanying obr
forecast because those support measures
are intended to be temporary and will be
self-terminating when uh energy
wholesale Energy prices fall back the
thing that created the problem in my
view was the fact alongside that
uh the chancellor chose to announce the
rolling back of National Insurance uh
increase
um and they slated increase in corporate
income taxes I wish you soon I could put
in place to pay for extra Health
spending and those were intended to be
permanent so they potentially have
implications for the sustainability of
the public finances
um now uh this trust during the
leadership campaign have claimed that
the 30 billion Headroom that was
available to the chancellor in March
could be used to finance those uh I my
very strong tuition given the
deterioration in uh economic
circumstances since the spring is that
that uh Headroom is no longer there and
in all probability there would be a
shortfall
so the um the extra elements announced
last week have just simply worsened that
shortfall and will need to be addressed
somehow uh quite possibly by uh cutting
government spending
yes and so what's the implications of
that do you think for spending on public
services
well
um if until we actually see the treasury
figuring and know what the chancellors
uh time Horizon is for getting the debt
to GDP ratio back onto a sustainable
path
um precisely what what is required uh
will be unclear but given the scale of
the
um tax cuts in the event last Friday uh
it's pointing to substantial cuts in
government spending and it should be
said that they would be taking place
against a set of cash limits which were
Set uh a year ago uh which assumed
relatively low inflation that made no
allowance for the fact that inflation
energy costs and so forth are
substantially higher so even
accommodating what's happened within the
existing cash limits would be extremely
demanding
um uh The Institute for fiscal Studies
have suggested uh that they need to be
raised uh significantly by you know the
order of 20 billion a year uh to even
just to compensate for the Direct
effects of the higher inflation on the
costs of government doing business so to
actually reduce public spending in these
circumstances is very demanding
um and it's all the order uh I think of
what we saw during the
um uh the the first uh first few years
of the uh well I guess it's the
coalition government uh from 2010 to uh
2015.
the austerity is what you're saying yeah
and what about interest rates what's
your forecast for how high they could go
given the rates of inflation we're
seeing now and seeing some of the
pressures on that rate
I think it's very difficult to uh to
make concrete forecasts of uh exactly
where they will go because it depends on
how economic circumstances unfold
obviously depends on uh what happens to
growth and more particularly inflation
what the bank is concerned about is that
the high level of current inflation
doesn't get embedded in the system
uh with higher wages higher prices
higher inflation expectations in the
future we don't know how strong those
so-called second round effects will be
so the bank will be monitoring uh them
as they unfold what is clear though I
think without any doubt is that bank
rate has to rise substantially
more from where it is at the moment
um and the bank even before the fiscal
announcement last week had indicated
that that was the case and that interest
rates would continue to rise for a while
uh so I think we're looking at a minimum
of something in the four percent range
uh some people in the markets are
conjecturing retires six
I wouldn't say it's impossible
um personally I suspect it won't need to
go as high as that because there will be
enough slowing in the economy anyway uh
to moderate those second round effects
which the bank are so worried about